once upon a time
there was a town and all of the people
were stuck but one girl
was different i really need this job
i'm sorry they told her you'll never
leave this place
so how did she escape
[Applause]
there was a game it's called panic
this year the winner is gonna take home
50 000.
each year there are new players
new challenges
you don't need panic to go to college
yeah
i do you could actually win just be
careful last year this game put two of
our kids in the ground
and someone was gonna pay uh guys
[Music]
starting
every player has a story you're not
afraid
everybody's afraid of something
every player is hiding something you and
me we can win this together
i think someone is trying to fix the
game
we know the games are organized by
judges we don't really know who's
involved
tell me the truth why are you playing
you got to know what to be afraid of
when to be afraid of it you got to know
the difference
once upon a time there was a town made
of lies
you